in reality there's no such thing as an
actual zero-sum game if we play a game
of chess yes technically one of us will
win one will lose but in practicality
we'll both get better at chess maybe
we'll become better friends maybe we'll
actually hate each other have a big
argument so there's always externalities
even to these zero-sum games that we
might play it's I think an error to not
truly Factor those in we can expand the
definition of games as well like
technically any kind of interaction that
you do you could consider it as a game
you know so if you are a Trader
technically you're playing the trading
game if you're a scientist you're
playing the science game certainly some
Industries are more like inclined to be
positive some or negative some but it's
important that we sort of just take a
step back and really ask ourselves
whether the career path we are choosing
is actually going to benefit the world
are we just optimizing for what's the
short-term win game for us